America is a nation divided.
So what should we do about it?
Well,
according to GOP
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene,
the solution is a national divorce.
That is a direct quote.
She tweeted this week
that we need to separate
by red and red states
and blue states
and shrink the federal government.
Everyone I talked to says this
from the sick
and disgusting woke culture issues
shoved down our throats
to the Democrats
traitorous America policies.
We are done She tweeted about it once
and then she tweeted about it again
and again.
And she just kept tweeting about it.
And if all of that wasn't
enough, Greene felt
the need to elaborate further
on all of this.
A national divorce is not a civil war.
It's actually separating
by red states and blue states
and making state rights and state
power a lot stronger than it is
right now.
It would be shrinking
the federal government.
I think it's something
that we should work towards
because, you know,
it's kind of the vision
that our founding fathers had
for America.
And I think it's a great one
at work in the beginning.
We just got it completely out of control.
It's crazy that I have to say this,
but the Civil War was fought to prevent
the red states and blue states
from splitting up right.
So exactly what is going on?
And she's from Georgia.
So since Biden won that,
that's now a blue state.
So what happens there?
There's a
whole discussion
at the beginning of this show.
Was about East Palestine, Ohio,
and the need for government in our lives.
And those are the discussions
that members of Congress
should be having about the
the role that government
must play in our lives
in a constructive way.
And she's talking about this divorce.
She's tweeting about it.
So we keep talking about it.
Of course,
it is preposterous on every level
and it's very divisive.
I would say that most couples,
before they get divorced,
go to counseling.
And I think Democrats
would be happy
to go through that counseling process
because here are the facts.
71% of the GDP, these are
this is getting to the practical reasons
why this would never work. Right.
71% of GDP comes from Biden counties.
Red states have higher poverty rates.
They collect more.
And federal entitlements.
They cannot be independent
because they are dependent
on a lot of these blue states.
And so these are
some of the practical reasons
that I think Democrats would love to have
this conversation.
At the same time, by 20, 40,
something like 30% of the Senate
will then represent
70% of the American people.
So there's also this discussion to have
about equal representation
that Democrats,
I think, have been itching to have,
even if an actual divorce is just
not at all.
And I think also the broader issue here
is Marjorie Taylor Greene. Right.
And she's not anymore
just this fringe character.
Here's Kevin McCarthy
to The New York Times in January.
If you're going to be in a fight,
you want Marjorie in your foxhole.
When she picks a fight,
she's going to fight
until the fight is over.
She reminds me of my friends
from high school
that we're going to stick together
all the way through.
He is all that he is for Kevin McCarthy.
I really think it's a mentality of
keep your friends close
and your enemies closer.
He made a very conservative, conservative
effort to bring her into the fold,
make her part of the family.
He thinks that that way
she can do us harm.
He has some control over her.
She's tried to play the inside game
and benefited her.
She now has desirable committee seats.
The problem with that
is that there is a huge risk
for Kevin McCarthy
because once you make her part
of the family
you're accountable
for anything that she does.
And so it is absolutely fair
game to ask Kevin McCarthy,
do you agree with X, Y, Z, outlanders
that Marjorie Taylor Greene made?
And so that is what you're going
to see going forward and wait.
There's more.
So Congressman Barrymore
introduced legislation to make the AR 15
the National Guard of America saying
we must send a message
that we will meet every attack
on our constitutional rights.
And on top of that,
he is joined by the one and only
George Santos. Take a listen.
This is a
gun manufactured
in the United States, creates
jobs in the United States,
some made in America gun
and I mean we have national everything
but why not have a National Guard?
It
said to the point of
look in this Congress
when you have a five seat majority
Every single member becomes important.
Every single member's
doings become significant.
And Kevin McCarthy hasn't
you know, pushed
Marjorie Taylor Greene to the side.
He hasn't pushed George Sanders
to the side either.
Yeah.
I think that oftentimes
with the Republicans, right.
There's there's typically a sort of
we're not
we're going to keep family issues
inside the House.
If there are disagreements policy-wise,
then we're not going to be quick
to lambaste somebody. Right.
If there's
someone like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who was saying something
that we don't disagree
that Republicans may disagree with,
they're not going to be so quick
to say to condemn her. Right.
And now that they have already
brought her back into the fold
after she had lost her
committee assignment,
it's going to be even more difficult
to sort of push her to the side again.
I actually wanted to point to something
that she was saying right where she said
this is the founders had this idea.
But what the founders are trying to do.
You think about George Washington
in his first speech
to Congress in 1790,
he was offering a national university
in order to build a national character,
in order to bring the country together
rather than then the sort of fracturing.
So it was an acknowledgment
that this was a sort of divided nation.
These were different colonies.
These were different states,
but they needed to be brought together
and held together
by some sort of national character.
Before we go, I just want to play
real quick.
The response from Romney and Manchin
to just the point that you're
making right there
You know, I
think Abraham Lincoln dealt
with that kind of insanity.
We're not going to divide the country.
It's united we stand, divided we fall.
Well, we're not called
a divided states of America.
We're called the United States.
I totally, absolutely,
vigorously disagree with her thought
process of even
dividing our country further than it is
So just to end on a positive note,
I mean, there are people out there
who get it,
who understand that this is nonsense,
but we have this person now
I mean, she's a congresswoman
saying this,
and it's reflective of something
that is out there in the country.
And it's really quite unfortunate.
I mean, we have a couple seconds.
It it's not about policy.
It's about her personal branding.
Yeah, I think that that's exactly.
And we'll see if it ends up
in the presidential campaign.
I could easily see the former president
picking up something like this.
But the reality is history and facts,
as you two both eloquently pointed out,
fly in the face of everything she said.
Absolutely.